Tasha: 怪不得给你也
Tasha: No wonder you...
Tasha: 哦是你吗
Tasha: Oh, is it you?
Jake:所以他所以你很懂是吧
Jake: So you know a lot, right?
Tasha: 是你断了那条吗
Tasha: Was it you who broke that?
Tasha: 不是你
Tasha: Wasn’t it you?
Jake:不是他的
Jake: It wasn’t him.
Jake:秀硕秀硕段子
Jake: Shure, Shure, tell a joke.
其他人: 不懂我就天天刷抖音短视频
Others: I don't get it, I just keep scrolling through Douyin short videos every day.
其他人: 很好玩开始赌石
Others: It's really fun, started gambling on stones.
其他人: 开始拍照
Others: Started taking pictures.
Jake:哦哦水切对
Jake: Oh, oh, water cutting, right.
其他人:对对很好
Others: Yes, yes, very good.
Lucia: 忒难用
Lucia: It's so hard to use.
Jake:我来帮你看看怎么办
Jake: Let me help you see how to do it.
Lucia: 就是要先把它剪到一个差不多的大小
Lucia: You just need to cut it to a reasonable size first.
Jake:剪成这个样子是吧
Jake: Cut it like this, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:他这个就是掉了嘛
Jake: This part just fell off.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 稍微垫一下
Lucia: Just pad it a little bit.
Lucia: 然后开始滑动
Lucia: Then start sliding.
Jake:可以啊开始
Jake: Alright, start.
Lucia:另另外那个剪刀在哪
Lucia: By the way, where are the other scissors?
Jake:另外我也没找着
Jake: By the way, I couldn't find them either.
Jake:学生小菜刀
Jake: Student's small kitchen knife.
Jake:小剪刀目测一下
Jake: Small scissors, just estimate it.
其他人: 目测一下这个圈 53
Others: Just estimate this circle, 53.
Lucia:我小时候做手工的
Lucia: I used to do crafts when I was a kid.
Lucia:难用了
Lucia: It's hard to use.
Tasha: 不是
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 你没有你没有你没有数是吧
Tasha: You didn't, you didn't, you didn't count, right?
Alice:差不多
Alice: Almost.
其他人: 56
Others: 56.
其他人: 其实刚刚前两条在试探你
Others: Actually, the first two were just testing you.
Tasha: 我一看你的手围我就知道54左右
Tasha: I can tell from the circumference of your hand that it's about 54.
其他人: 哈哈哈又没秀了啊
Others: Hahaha, didn't show off again, huh?
Jake:又被秀了
Jake: Showed off again.
Katrina:  其实我根本不知道我多 54
Katrina: Actually, I have no idea how much, 54.
陌生人: 真的吗
Stranger: Really?
Tasha: 嗯真的
Tasha: Yes, really.
陌生人:我以后就直接买54就行了
Stranger: So I can just buy 54 from now on.
Jake: 不会不会不会
Jake: No, no, no.
陌生人:我买买不了这些东西
Stranger: I can't buy these things anyway.
陌生人:您这句话我就放心了
Stranger: Your words put me at ease.
陌生人:行家呀
Stranger: You're an expert.
Jake:呃最好对对对
Jake: Uh, it's best, yes, yes, yes.
Jake:黑色的再贴一下
Jake: Stick the black one again.
Tasha: 我是经常买
Tasha: I buy this often.
其他人: 这款就非常的实用
Others: This one is really practical.
Lucia: 感觉我跟机器人似的
Lucia: I feel like a robot.
Lucia: 还有手缘
Lucia: And with hand fate.
其他人: 富婆不想努力了
Others: The rich lady doesn't want to work hard anymore.
Shure:  经常买，我真绷不住了
Shure: Buying often, I really can't hold it anymore.
Lucia: 这个真得用
Lucia: This really needs to be used.
Lucia: 这真得用剪刀剪一下
Lucia: This really needs to be cut with scissors.
Lucia:这我能用手给他撕开啊
Lucia: I can tear this open with my hands.
Jake:这个撕不开
Jake: This can't be torn open.
Lucia:你估算的这个大小准吗不准
Lucia: Are you sure about this size? No, it's not accurate.
Lucia:不准
Lucia: Not accurate.
Jake:也还行吧
Jake: It's okay.
Lucia:也还行差别不是特别大对
Lucia: It's okay, the difference isn't that big, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:来捏捏给他塑个形
Jake: Come on, pinch it to shape it.
Lucia:还是差一点
Lucia: It's still a bit off.
Jake:我看一看
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:海关如果没把我镊子给收了
Jake: If customs hadn't taken my tweezers.
Jake:我现在就能用
Jake: I could use them now.
Jake:镊子就是海关把我
Jake: The tweezers, the customs took them.
Lucia:镊子
Lucia: Tweezers.
Jake:呃就是就是
Jake: Uh, I mean, I mean...
Jake:那那那螺丝刀
Jake: That, that, that screwdriver.
Lucia:哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Jake:里边有很细的那种
Jake: There's a very fine one inside.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Jake:这个还行吧
Jake: This is okay, right?
Tasha: 没有这个
Tasha: Not this one.
Tasha: 原味是最好吃的
Tasha: The original flavor is the best.
Tasha: 你居然能把这一边折上
Tasha: You actually folded this side up.
Lucia: 那那那还行
Lucia: Well, well, that's okay.
Jake:试试试试看
Jake: Try it, try it, see.
Jake:看疼不疼
Jake: See if it hurts.
Jake:如果疼我们再包一层
Jake: If it hurts, we'll wrap another layer.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 这是岫玉不是翡翠
Alice: This is Xiuyu, not jade.
Alice: 就不在你那个评价体系里面
Alice: So it's not in your evaluation system.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 哎我刚才用了
Tasha: Oh, I just used it.
Tasha: 眼镜布
Tasha: The eyeglass cloth.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This one.
Jake:怎么都乱扔东西了
Jake: Why is everyone throwing stuff around?
Tasha: 谁乱扔啊
Tasha: Who's throwing stuff?
Jake:我我我对不起对不起
Jake: Me, me, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Jake:我乱扔蒜
Jake: I was throwing garlic around.
Alice: 什么算什么
Alice: What do you mean?
Tasha: 也是开石头也是开石头
Tasha: It's like opening stones, opening stones.
其他人: 你开过石头吗
Others: Have you ever opened stones?
Tasha: 我没开过石头
Tasha: I've never opened stones.
其他人: 我我就给你几块石头你开一下
Others: I'll give you some stones to open.
Jake:哼哪里有啊
Jake: Hah, where are they?
Tasha: 我我不会挑石头
Tasha: I don't know how to pick stones.
Tasha: 我会挑榴莲
Tasha: I can pick durians.
Tasha: 挑石头还得再练几年
Tasha: I'll need a few more years to learn how to pick stones.
其他人:我帮你洗了
Others: I washed it for you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈好
Tasha: Hahaha, okay.
Tasha: 教你点假的
Tasha: I'll teach you something fake.
其他人: 你天天叫他下来
Others: You call him down every day.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你有以前学过吗
Tasha: Have you learned before?
Tasha: 你知道他都学多少了吗
Tasha: Do you know how much he's learned?
Tasha: 你都跟不上他了
Tasha: You can't keep up with him.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:怎么能上去
Jake: How do I get up there?
Jake:给你瞅一个
Jake: Let me show you one.
其他人: 昨天学金铲铲啊
Others: Learned how to use the Golden Shovel yesterday?
Alice:你也学会了吧
Alice: You learned it too, right?
Lucia: 嗯我学会了
Lucia: Yeah, I learned it.
Tasha: 你卖100 你净赚
Tasha: You sell it for 100, you make a profit.
Lucia: 你可以做成做成电子版
Lucia: You can make a digital version.
Lucia: 然后就是以300块钱卖电子版
Lucia: Then sell the digital version for 300.
Lucia: 你可以卖无数个
Lucia: You can sell countless copies.
Lucia: 一本万利啊
Lucia: It's a goldmine.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 那个的话
Tasha: In that case,
Tasha: 用厨房纸巾擦会擦的更干净点
Tasha: using kitchen paper will make it cleaner.
Tasha: 你知道用哪个
Tasha: You know which one to use.
Tasha: 在楼上就用这个
Tasha: Use this one upstairs.
Tasha: 就用这个
Tasha: Just use this.
Jake:厨房纸巾
Jake: Kitchen paper towels.
Jake:在楼上吧
Jake: Upstairs, maybe?
Tasha: 在楼上你要在这找找
Tasha: If it's upstairs, you should look around here.
Jake:找找去
Jake: Go look for it.
Tasha: 就在这呀
Tasha: It's right here.
Jake:二楼煎牛排
Jake: Cooking steak on the second floor.
Jake:二楼开火
Jake: Cooking on the second floor.
Jake:你你可以煎牛排
Jake: You can cook the steak.
Jake:也可以或者你也
Jake: Or you can...
Jake:你也可以先和和面
Jake: You can start by kneading the dough.
Jake:然后再去煎牛排
Jake: And then cook the steak later.
Tasha: 这些杯子拿走他很危险
Tasha: Move these cups away, they're dangerous.
Jake:眼镜我可以站你旁边给你拍
Jake: Glasses, I can stand next to you and film.
Lucia: 这也没找着啊
Lucia: Couldn't find it here either.
Lucia: 我感觉这块也没有啊
Lucia: I don't think it's here either.
Jake:没有纸巾
Jake: No paper towels.
Jake:对嘿哎
Jake: Yeah, hey.
Jake:有的有的有的有的有的
Jake: Got it, got it, got it, got it.
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is this it?
Jake:不是哎哎
Jake: No, hey.
Lucia: 是这个吗
Lucia: Is this it?
Lucia: 我怎么记得今天微微买了那种
Lucia: I thought Tasha bought some today.
Lucia: 就是那种纸巾
Lucia: Like those paper towels.
Lucia: 吸水纸
Lucia: Absorbent paper.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 哦您在新加坡见过没
Lucia: Oh, have you seen it in Singapore?
Jake:是卷很很大的那种吗
Jake: The big roll type?
Jake:对就是那种
Jake: Yeah, that kind.
Lucia: 你先先问一下他是不是这个吧
Lucia: Maybe ask if this is it?
Jake:好先带一波下去
Jake: Okay, let's take one batch downstairs.
Lucia:我感觉他好像说的是那个
Lucia: I think he's talking about that one.
Jake:就是先汇报一下
Jake: Let's report this first.
Jake:嗯先有这些东西汇报
Jake: Yeah, let's report what we have first.
Jake:然后再看领导怎么说
Jake: And see what the boss says.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:至少先有点进展是吧
Lucia: At least we made some progress, right?
Jake:对对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:你说话的语气
Jake: Your tone.
Jake:现在有东西了
Jake: Now we have something.
Lucia: 微微你说的是那种
Lucia: Tasha, are you talking about that kind of...
Lucia: 没有没有我是我是说他居然知道这个
Lucia: No, no, no, I'm saying that he actually knows about this.
Tasha: 做甜品是需要无油无水的啊
Tasha: Making desserts requires no oil and no water.
Tasha: 好厉害啊
Tasha: That's amazing.
Jake:好牛逼
Jake: So awesome.
Lucia: 你说的是那种吸水纸吧
Lucia: Are you talking about that kind of absorbent paper?
Lucia: 但是我们只找到了这个
Lucia: But we only found this one.
Lucia: 这个吗哦
Lucia: This one, oh?
Tasha: 在那啊OK好的
Tasha: Over there? Okay, got it.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我就记得你好像买了一卷这个
Lucia: I remember you bought a roll of this.
Jake:先打过来
Jake: Send it over first.
Lucia: 那个那个超好用
Lucia: That one is super useful.
Lucia: 特别好用可以
Lucia: Really useful, it can...
Shure:  摔了就不好摔了
Shure: If it breaks, it won't be easy to handle.
其他人:应该拿下
Others: We should take it down.
其他人: 毫无生活经验的标准
Others: Totally inexperienced.
其他人: 哈哈哈你这把为什么这么短
Others: Hahaha, why is this one so short?
Lucia: 这把为什么这么短
Lucia: Why is this one so short?
其他人:很难很难拿
Others: It's hard, hard to hold.
Tasha: 是的呢要不你去让厂家生产改一下
Tasha: Yeah, maybe you should ask the manufacturer to make some changes.
其他人:厂你买这个
Others: The manufacturer, did you buy this?
Tasha: 好你买的肯定比我好
Tasha: Sure, what you bought must be better than mine.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:卡住了卡住了卡住了
Jake: It's stuck, it's stuck, it's stuck.
其他人:一句都说不出来
Others: Can't say a word.
Tasha: 要开始了是吗
Tasha: Is it starting?
Tasha: 这就要开始了是吗
Tasha: Is it starting now?
Jake:呀我去
Jake: Oh, darn it.
Katrina:  我很会做饭
Katrina: I'm really good at cooking.
Katrina:  哈哈哈你很会做饭好好
Katrina: Hahaha, you're really good at cooking, alright.
Katrina:  这个相机开了吗
Katrina: Is this camera on?
Jake:开了闪了
Jake: It's on, it's flashing.
Jake:就是开了
Jake: It's on.
Jake:他他他我也不懂为什么
Jake: He, he, he, I don't get why either.
Jake:反正他是开了
Jake: Anyway, it's on.
Jake:每个相机都有自己的个性
Jake: Every camera has its own personality.
其他人: 这不是check一个吗
Others: Isn't this just to check?
Jake:对是
Jake: Yeah, it is.
Jake:我们主要check他
Jake: We mainly check it.
Jake:充电宝上面的灯和字是不是亮的
Jake: Are the lights and text on the power bank on?
Jake:关了就这是和面用的
Jake: If they're off, it's for kneading dough.
Jake:这不行这不行
Jake: This won't work, this won't work.
Tasha: 都可以啊
Tasha: It's all fine.
Tasha: 怎么用都可以
Tasha: You can use it however you like.
Lucia: 你带着那外套
Lucia: Are you bringing that jacket?
Lucia: 这样我就可以把它揣口袋里了
Lucia: Then I can put it in my pocket.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  打这个里边
Katrina: Put it in here.
Katrina:  打这个里边吗
Katrina: Put it in here?
其他人:有可能是打
Others: Maybe put it in.
其他人:但是你别先打
Others: But don't put it in first.
其他人:你要你要打他一会就就该教育你了
Others: If you do, he'll teach you a lesson.
其他人:我就不会
Others: I won't.
Jake:他不理你
Jake: He'll ignore you.
其他人:他竟然没说呢
Others: He didn't even say anything.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人:在推测哈哈
Others: Just guessing, haha.
Jake:他不理你怎么办
Jake: What if he ignores you?
其他人:他不理我就打
Others: If he ignores me, I'll hit him.
Jake:好的哈哈
Jake: Okay, haha.
Tasha: 今天晚上做提拉米苏吗
Tasha: Are we making tiramisu tonight?
Tasha: 是的熟的吧
Tasha: Yes, cooked, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:确实哈哈哈
Jake: For sure, haha.
Jake:打打了一个熟蛋
Jake: Cracked a cooked egg.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 啊那个是熟蛋
Tasha: Oh, that was a cooked egg.
Jake:对打不出蛋黄哈哈
Jake: Yeah, can't get the yolk out, haha.
Tasha: 要用蛋清
Tasha: Need the egg whites.
Tasha: 那个打蛋盆呢
Tasha: Where's the egg-beating bowl?
Jake:打蛋盆
Jake: The egg-beating bowl.
Tasha: 打蛋盆呢
Tasha: Where's the egg-beating bowl?
Jake:什么盆
Jake: What bowl?
Katrina:  盆
Katrina: The bowl.
Jake:有他都有
Jake: He has everything.
Jake:那确实
Jake: For sure.
Jake:易烊千玺哎
Jake: Jackson Yee, hey.
Jake:我们好像是什么时候看到的
Jake: When did we see him?
Jake:那个王源
Jake: That Roy Wang.
Jake:还是哦
Jake: Still, oh
其他人:是那个去去去
Others: It's that go, go, go
其他人: 买瑞幸coffee的哦
Others: To buy Luckin Coffee, oh
Tasha: 手也擦干吧
Tasha: Dry your hands too
其他人:买芙蓉王时能看到王源
Others: You might see Wang Yuan when buying Furongwang
其他人:芙蓉王源
Others: Furongwang Yuan
其他人:尼古丁丁
Others: Nicotine
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人:坏了我们顺序要少于顺序
Others: Oh no, we messed up the order
其他人:TF不好意思
Others: TF, sorry
Jake:哈哈完了完了
Jake: Haha, it's over, it's over
其他人:我北半球我能收获一大批
Others: I'm in the northern hemisphere, I can harvest a lot
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 这个要保持绝对的干
Tasha: This has to stay completely dry
其他人:欧欧奥来讲还是赚哈哈哈
Others: Oh, oh, oh, it's still profitable, haha
Tasha: 行外面
Tasha: Okay, outside
其他人: 这打蛋器你要不来打
Others: Do you want to use this egg beater?
Tasha: 只加蛋清
Tasha: Just add egg whites
Jake:来他会打
Jake: Come, he can beat
Jake:他来打打到打到
Jake: He'll beat it, beat it
Tasha:这里面打几个
Tasha: How many to beat in here?
Jake:他可会打了
Jake: He can really beat it
Jake:只加蛋清
Jake: Just add egg whites
Tasha: 不用你打进去就行了
Tasha: No need, just beat it in
Tasha: 直接打直接打
Tasha: Just beat it directly
Jake:他用手可以打蛋黄
Jake: He can beat the yolk by hand
Jake:蛋黄弄出来
Jake: Separate the yolk
Jake:这么高级可以
Jake: So advanced, okay
Katrina:  蛋黄不要了
Katrina: Don't need the yolk
Tasha: 蛋壳不要了
Tasha: Don't need the shell
Jake:我来打个蛋
Jake: Let me beat an egg
Jake:哈哈哎
Jake: Haha, hey
Tasha: 哎等等等等
Tasha: Hey, wait, wait, wait
Tasha: 我怕打坏了
Tasha: I'm afraid I'll break it
Lucia: 要要一个蛋就倒一次
Lucia: You need to pour once per egg
Lucia: 否则的话就很有
Lucia: Otherwise, it's very
Lucia: 不然的话后果很严重
Lucia: Otherwise, the consequences are serious
Tasha: OK第二位学徒上场就要分开
Tasha: OK, second apprentice, you need to separate
Tasha: 不用你直接抱就行了
Tasha: No need, just hold it directly
Jake:秀手法这是手法
Jake: Show your skills, this is technique
Jake:这是直接把蛋黄弄破
Jake: Just break the yolk directly.
其他人:他必须要展示一下
Others: He has to show it off.
Tasha: 你把蛋黄弄破了你就死定了
Tasha: If you break the yolk, you're doomed.
Tasha: 哈哈活着
Tasha: Haha, still alive.
Jake:活着还活着
Jake: Still alive, still alive.
Katrina:  牛哎哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Amazing, hahaha.
Jake:傻逼啊哈哈哈
Jake: You idiot, hahaha.
Lucia: 膨胀了膨胀了
Lucia: Got too arrogant.
Tasha: 受不了了
Tasha: Can't handle it.
Jake:你这有变化吗
Jake: Did you make any changes?
Jake:你这来回倒这蛋黄到这哎
Jake: Moving the yolk back and forth here.
Alice: 这蛋黄到这哎
Alice: Moving the yolk here.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What for?
Tasha: 蛋清蛋清蛋清
Tasha: Egg whites, egg whites.
其他人: 需要这个完整
Others: It needs to be whole.
Tasha: 嗯好
Tasha: Got it.
Tasha: 下一个下一个
Tasha: Next one, next one.
Jake:下一个谁要打下一个
Jake: Who's next? Who wants to go next?
Jake:来来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on.
其他人:来来来我不敢打
Others: Come on, come on, I don't dare.
其他人:我只能打打
Others: I can only try.
其他人:打进去就不错了
Others: Getting it in is good enough.
其他人:你别把蛋黄打碎
Others: Don't break the yolk.
其他人:切都没有问题
Others: No problem cutting it.
Jake:哦我发现大家都是高手
Jake: Oh, I realize everyone here is an expert.
其他人:各显神通
Others: Each has their own tricks.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: OK下一位
Tasha: OK, next one.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哦
Tasha: Hahaha, oh.
Katrina:  坏了我感觉
Katrina: Oh no, I feel it.
Jake:完完球
Jake: It's over.
Katrina:  哈哈玩球
Katrina: Haha, it's over.
Jake:哎可以可以
Jake: Hey, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:董莎莎来了董莎莎来
Jake: Here comes Jack, here comes Jack.
Jake:没关系没关系没关系
Jake: It's alright, it's alright, it's alright.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:一定成功
Jake: You'll succeed for sure.
小薇 : 有有有在这呢
Tasha: There, there, there it is.
Jake:有的有的有的有的
Jake: Got it, got it, got it.
Jake:可以成功
Jake: You can do it.
Tasha: 给你玩会five goals
Tasha: Here, play some Five Goals.
其他人:我只会最基础的
Others: I only know the basics.
其他人:因为因为当我需要打鸡蛋的时候
Others: Because, because when I need to crack eggs...
小薇     : 呃要接一个那个转
Tasha: Um, you need to catch this spin.
其他人:只会用来炒鸡蛋
Others: I only use it to make scrambled eggs.
Tasha: 哈哈啊
Tasha: Haha, ah.
Tasha: 在这
Tasha: Right here.
其他人:哦这是这个是吧
Others: Oh, is this it?
Tasha: 对对对哎呦我操
Tasha: Yes, yes, oh my god.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha: 那个没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Tasha: 你应该知道
Tasha: You should know.
Lucia: 那必须已经非常熟练了
Lucia: You must be really good at it already.
Jake:可以出师了
Jake: You can graduate now.
其他人:他干嘛去
Others: Where's he going?
其他人:我好高级
Others: I feel so advanced.
其他人:感觉非常厉害
Others: It feels really impressive.
其他人:卧槽我要学一下打五个单
Others: Damn, I need to learn how to crack five eggs at once.
其他人:五个蛋试一下
Others: Try cracking five eggs.
Jake:开始偷了
Jake: Starting to cheat.
Jake:哈哈哈你直接背就好了
Jake: Haha, you can just memorize it.
Tasha: 50克清水
Tasha: 50 grams of water.
Jake:围观
Jake: Observing.
其他人:哎那个单
Others: Hey, that...
其他人:卧槽我之前你这个打蛋
其他人:你这个打蛋可以打多长时间
其他人:20分钟吗
Others: 20 minutes?
Tasha: 20分钟我打服了
Tasha: 20 minutes and I'm done.
Tasha: 最高5分钟
Tasha: Maximum 5 minutes.
Tasha: 都打到不能再打了
Tasha: Until I can't crack anymore.
其他人:我在我家
Others: At my place...
其他人:我自己打篮球怎么打都打不起来
Others: No matter how I try, I can't get the hang of it.
其他人:你自己还打嗯
Others: You still try on your own, huh?
其他人:加加加多少
Others: Add, add how much?
其他人:这个怎么锁
Others: How do you lock this?
其他人:你把你的配料贡献出来
Others: Share your ingredients.
Tasha: 就他在这呢吗
Tasha: Is he here?
其他人:就他有在这吗
Others: Is he here?
Lucia: 你那按进去对
Lucia: You press it in, right.
Lucia: 顺着他就就按一下就可以了
Lucia: Just press it like this.
Lucia: 按比例对按进去
Lucia: Push it in proportionately.
Lucia: 只要他不掉就他就按上了称
Lucia: As long as it doesn't fall off, it’s good.
Lucia: 对就已经好了嗯
Lucia: Yeah, it's already done, hmm.
Tasha: 怎么大家都看着我
Tasha: Why is everyone looking at me?
Tasha: 我有点紧张了
Tasha: I'm a bit nervous now.
Jake:这是一代宗师和门下弟子
Jake: This is the grandmaster and his disciples.
Jake:哈哈哈我想要矿泉水
Jake: Hahaha, I want some bottled water.
Tasha: 清水水
Tasha: Clear water.
Jake:师傅想喝水
Jake: The master wants water.
Tasha: 不是我想喝水
Tasha: No, I want water.
Tasha: 这药水
Tasha: This is medicine water.
Jake:矿泉水
Jake: Bottled water.
Lucia: 这是纯净水吗
Lucia: Is this purified water?
Lucia:  啊那行
Lucia: Ah, that’s fine then.
Lucia: 我记得刚刚应该有几个杯子
Lucia: I remember there were a few cups earlier.
Lucia: 是我洗过的
Lucia: I washed them.
Lucia: 是这个吗
Lucia: Is it this one?
Lucia: 管他呢冲一下
Lucia: Whatever, just rinse it.
Tasha: 哎干什么
Tasha: Hey, what are you doing?
Jake:比划比划
Jake: Just showing something.
Jake:电脑没插
Jake: The computer isn't plugged in.
Tasha: 等等会给你用
Tasha: Wait a bit, I'll let you use it.
Tasha: 等会给你用
Tasha: Wait a bit, I’ll let you use it.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
其他人:那个打单的呢
Others: Where's the receipt?
其他人:那个去哪里了
Others: Where did it go?
Lucia: 啥呀
Lucia: What?
Tasha: 多了0.9克
Tasha: It’s 0.9 grams too much.
其他人:有关系吗
Others: Does it matter?
Jake:喝掉喝掉
Jake: Drink it, drink it.
Jake:哈哈哈够吗
Jake: Hahaha, is it enough?
Lucia: 够了好的
Lucia: Yes, it's enough.
其他人:你不去皮吗
Others: Aren’t you going to peel it?
其他人:清水加50110
Others: Add 50110 to the clear water.
其他人:然后100
Others: Then 100.
其他人:多多奖励
Others: Add more rewards.
Tasha:您来搅
Tasha: You stir it.
Jake:这个搅不用
Jake: No need to stir this.
Tasha:不用
Tasha: No need?
Jake:哈哈哈不要
Jake: Hahaha, no need.
Tasha:不要哈哈
Tasha: No, haha
Lucia:不要那个这么小的碗会打飞出去吗
Lucia: No, will such a small bowl fly away?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人:搅到什么程度
Others: How much should we stir it?
Tasha:找到他们俩完全融合
Tasha: Until they are completely blended.
Jake:水和油还能
Jake: Water and oil can still...
其他人:水和油还能融合吗
Others: Can water and oil still blend?
Jake:就是可以融合
Jake: Yes, they can blend.
Jake:师傅说可以融合
Jake: The master said they can blend.
其他人:好
Others: Okay.
Jake:哈哈哈不没法牛顿算什么
Jake: Hahaha, no, Newton doesn't count.
Shure: 牛顿跑了给师傅
Shure: Newton ran away to the master.
其他人:你是不是埋进去
Others: Are you buried in it?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈可以可以可以如何
Jake: Hahahahaha, okay, okay, okay.
Tasha:找到完全融合
Tasha: Until it's completely blended.
其他人:你觉得如何
Others: What do you think?
Tasha:我觉得没有
Tasha: I don't think so.
Shure: 咱俩这辈子再也不会
Shure: We'll never do this again in our lives.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:还能变成金子
Jake: It can still turn into gold.
Shure: 哈哈我从小接受的金是不允许我干
Shure: Haha, from a young age, I was taught that gold shouldn't be tampered with.
Jake:这种金有水混合物
Jake: This kind of gold is a mixture of water.
Shure: 哈哈确实
Shure: Haha, indeed.
Lucia:哈
Lucia: Ha.
其他人:但是变成特别小
Others: But it becomes very small.
其他人:的那种对
Others: Like that, right.
Shure: 一个个小的
Shure: Little by little.
其他人:这个时候你给他加一点那个洗衣剂
Others: At this point, you add a bit of detergent.
其他人:也就是乳化
Others: That is, to emulsify.
其他人:哈哈哈别吧还能吃吗
Others: Hahaha, no way, can we still eat it?
Tasha:我帮你倒下一个东西
Tasha: I'll pour in the next ingredient.
其他人:怎么感觉搅成面糊的感觉
Others: Why does it feel like it's turning into dough?
其他人:那个大的都去哪了
Others: Where did the big pieces go?
Lucia:这个吗在这啊
Lucia: This one? It's here.
Jake:装蛋清哦
Jake: Put the egg whites in.
Lucia:哦那个在冰箱里
Lucia: Oh, that one is in the fridge.
Tasha:完了完了
Tasha: It's over, it's over.
其他人:还要冰一会是吧
Others: Does it need to be chilled for a while?
Lucia:对对对他是我们接下来会
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah, he's the one we're going to use next.
Lucia:用到的妙妙小工具
Lucia: The magical little tool we'll use.
Jake:哈哈哈妙妙妙妙小冰壶
Jake: Hahaha, the magical little curling stone.
Tasha:多少克
Tasha: How many grams?
其他人:你先去皮
Others: You peel it first.
Tasha:去了放放
Tasha: Peel it and put it.
其他人:你这你这
Others: This, this...
Tasha:没关系我知道了
Tasha: It's okay, I got it.
其他人:40.8叫加50
Others: 40.8, let's call it 50.
其他人:多一点多一点
Others: A bit more, a bit more.
其他人:卧槽精益求精
Others: Wow, striving for perfection.
其他人:没事多一点多一点多一点
Others: It's fine, a bit more, a bit more.
其他人:多吃一口
Others: Eat a bit more.
Jake:多吃1/500
Jake: Eat 1/500 more.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:继续搅
Tasha: Keep stirring.
其他人:我靠可以拿那个打蛋器吗
Others: Wow, can we use that whisk?
Alice:不可以
Alice: No.
Jake:哈哈喜欢打碗的
Jake: Haha, likes to hit the bowl.
其他人:这个可以
Others: This one is fine.
Tasha:那个太大了
Tasha: That one is too big.
其他人:这正经面糊这味
Others: This is the proper batter smell.
其他人:纸杯蛋糕
Others: Cupcakes.
Tasha:不是的
Tasha: No, it's not.
其他人:哦这肉松小
Others: Oh, this is meat floss...
Tasha:搅了吗
Tasha: Did you stir it?
其他人:搅了
Others: Stirred it.
Jake:不带劲啊
Jake: It's not exciting.
其他人:来看着很有食欲
Others: It looks appetizing.
其他人:我来上脸
Others: Let me give it a face.
Jake:强度你这几档的
Jake: What's your intensity level?
Jake:2档的这5档的
Jake: Level 2, this is level 5.
Jake:这个要涨到多少
Jake: How high should this go?
其他人:还要加
Others: Add more.
其他人:哎呦我操
Others: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:倒到这个里面来吧
Tasha: Pour it into this one.
Jake:哦现在你可以用你的机器了哦
Jake: Oh, now you can use your machine.
Tasha:可以用那个蛋抽了
Tasha: Can use that whisk.
Tasha:那个那个不是机器
Tasha: That, that one's not a machine.
Jake:机器插链了哦
Jake: The machine is linked.
Jake:蛋抽哦
Jake: The egg beater.
Jake:还没到机器对
Jake: It's not time for the machine yet.
Lucia:好吧
Lucia: Okay.
其他人:这个碗底不要了吗
Others: Are we done with this bowl?
Tasha:不用了好
Tasha: No need, it's fine.
其他人:所以说你刚刚进一球就没系列了
Others: So, you didn't make a series after scoring one ball?
其他人:是为了让他配比是不是
Others: Is it to match the ratio?
Tasha:配比是对的
Tasha: The ratio is correct.
其他人:那个得洗一下
Others: That needs to be washed.
Tasha:洗了之后用那个厨房纸巾擦一擦
Tasha: After washing, use the kitchen paper to wipe it.
Tasha:不要干燥哦
Tasha: Don't dry it.
Jake:他没开光肿
Jake: It hasn't opened yet, swollen.
其他人:配料什么的
Others: What about the ingredients?
Tasha:什么配料
Tasha: What ingredients?
Alice:我们的快递到了吗
Alice: Has our package arrived?
Tasha:糖
Tasha: Sugar.
其他人:不是还有15克的糖
Others: Isn't there 15 grams of sugar?
Alice:在哪呢
Alice: Where is it?
其他人:忘了
Others: Forgot.
Tasha:那就现在加吧哈哈哈
Tasha: Then add it now, hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Jake:好的哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, hahaha.
其他人:失误失误
Others: Mistake, mistake.
Jake:没有菜单不对
Jake: The menu is incorrect.
其他人:OK可以少加点糖
Others: OK, we can add less sugar.
Jake:对应该菜单回去修改一下
Jake: Yes, the menu needs to be revised.
其他人:应该什么时候加糖
Others: When should we add the sugar?
Jake:就现在就现在就现在就现在
Jake: Right now, right now, right now.
Jake:这没差别吧
Jake: There's no difference, right?
Jake:这应该没差别
Jake: There shouldn't be any difference.
其他人:不太懂他
Others: I don't quite understand him.
Jake:还没有发生什么化学变化
Jake: No chemical changes have happened yet.
其他人:师傅你怎么了
Others: Master, what's wrong?
Shure: 说我什么坏话了又
Shure: Talking bad about me again?
Shure: 他要到西天拜佛取真经
Shure: He's going to the West to get the true scriptures.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人:其实底料都是一样的
Others: Actually, the base ingredients are the same.
Shure: 咱们晚饭吃什么呀老板
Shure: What are we having for dinner, boss?
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
其他人:你调的那个面包坯子都是一样
Others: The dough you made is all the same.
Shure: 咱们晚饭吃什么呀
Shure: What are we having for dinner?
Shure: 老板
Shure: Boss.
Jake:麦当劳麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's, McDonald's burgers.
Shure: 麦当劳麦当劳
Shure: McDonald's, McDonald's.
Tasha:麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burgers.
Shure: 什么什么时候点一下呀
Shure: When are we ordering?
Tasha:慢慢慢蛋清
Tasha: Slowly, slowly, egg whites.
Jake:啊现在是啊
Jake: Ah, now?
Lucia:蛋清啊现在拿下来是吧嗯
Lucia: Egg whites, yeah, take them down now, right?
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yes.
其他人:哪有你这样打的
Others: Who beats it like that?
Jake:哈哈哈我觉得他这
Jake: Hahaha, I think it's...
Lucia:我觉得他这
Lucia: I think it's...
Lucia:他这个已经达到那个打蛋器的五档了
Lucia: It's already on the fifth gear of the mixer.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha.
Tasha:麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burgers.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burgers.
Jake:加点
Jake: Add some.
其他人:哈哈菠萝可以啊
Others: Haha, pineapple is fine.
其他人:可以啊要不要加点
Others: It's fine, do you want to add some?
Jake:加个菠萝
Jake: Add a pineapple.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人:师傅要不要加入菠萝
Others: Chef, do you want to add pineapple?
其他人:菠萝肉松小杯前面加点茉莉花茶
Others: Pineapple, meat floss, a small cup, and add some jasmine tea in front.
其他人:或者这个葡萄
Others: Or these grapes.
Shure: 他要到西天拜佛去取经
Shure: He needs to go west to worship Buddha and fetch scriptures.
Jake:师傅喜欢吃瓜子
Jake: The chef likes eating sunflower seeds.
Jake:哈哈哈不是瓜
Jake: Hahaha, not the melon.
Jake:瓜子仁我觉得烤一烤可以
Jake: Sunflower seeds, I think roasting them is good.
Tasha:来来来你来打这个吧
Tasha: Come on, you do this.
Tasha:好了好了
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Jake:这面糊里面放点花生仁吧
Jake: Put some peanuts in this batter.
Jake:是吧合理吧
Jake: Right? Reasonable, right?
Lucia:我得再来个杯子
Lucia: I need another cup.
Lucia:咦又没了
Lucia: Huh, it's gone again.
Lucia:我刚洗那些上哪去了
Lucia: Where did the ones I just washed go?
Tasha:打吧
Tasha: Beat it.
Tasha:不不不
Tasha: No, no, no.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burgers.
Tasha:我还以为你真会
Tasha: I thought you really knew how.
Jake:哎搜不到麦当劳
Jake: Ugh, can't find McDonald's.
Shure: 我操这没有麦当劳
Shure: Damn, there's no McDonald's here.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why not?
Tasha:停停
Tasha: Stop, stop.
Shure: 不会吧
Shure: No way.
其他人:你去那个麦当劳小程序里看一看
Others: Check the McDonald's mini program.
Tasha:开
Tasha: Open it.
Shure: 没有
Shure: Nothing.
Tasha:不用
Tasha: No need.
其他人:美团呢
Others: How about Meituan?
Tasha:第一次要打到他有
Tasha: Try to hit it so it shows up.
Shure: 卧槽真没有麦当劳
Shure: Damn, really no McDonald's.
Jake:谁有麦当劳小程序
Jake: Who has the McDonald's mini program?
Jake:你有吗我有我有
Jake: Do you have it? I have, I have.
Tasha:我要
Tasha: I want it.
Jake:来来来试试
Jake: Come, come, try it.
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Tasha:麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha:麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Jake:因为没有
Jake: Because there's none.
Jake:美团上没有
Jake: Not on Meituan.
Tasha:嗯这样子
Tasha: Oh, like this.
Tasha:有这种细密的小气泡
Tasha: It has these tiny bubbles.
Tasha:可以加第二次糖
Tasha: You can add sugar a second time.
Tasha:哎呀没事没关系
Tasha: Ah, it's okay, no worries.
Tasha:打到现在
Tasha: Beat it now.
Tasha:打到他提起来不会掉下来
Tasha: Beat it till it doesn't fall when lifted.
Tasha:呃提起来有小弯钩就行
Tasha: Uh, lift it up to have a small hook.
Tasha:你没有呢
Tasha: You don't have it.
Tasha:远远没有
Tasha: Far from it.
Jake:哎呦只能只能到店取餐呢
Jake: Oh, you can only pick it up at the store.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What does that mean?
Lucia:那就找个跑腿喽好
Lucia: Then just find an errand service, okay?
Tasha:那就找个跑腿喽
Tasha: Then just find an errand service.
Jake:啊照片
Jake: Uh, picture.
Jake:找个跑腿嗯
Jake: Find an errand service, hmm.
Lucia:啊啊
Lucia: Ah, ah.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha:真的送不到吗
Tasha: Really can't deliver?
Jake:师傅说要把它给提起来
Jake: The master said we need to lift it up.
Jake:不行然后不行
Jake: No, it won't work.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:妈的别人听有一种好
Lucia: Damn, it sounds nice to others.
Jake:香的哈哈哈
Jake: Smells good, hahaha.
Lucia:这能尝一口吗
Lucia: Can I have a taste?
Tasha:你尝吧
Tasha: Go ahead.
Lucia:会怎么样
Lucia: What will happen?
Tasha:不会怎么样的
Tasha: Nothing will happen.
Tasha:都是吃的难道还能死吗
Tasha: It's all edible, you won't die from it.
Lucia:奶盖是这么做的
Lucia: Is this how milk foam is made?
Tasha:奶盖不是这么做的
Tasha: No, that's not how you make milk foam.
Tasha:奶盖是奶油奶酪加淡奶油
Tasha: Milk foam is made with cream cheese and light cream.
其他人:奶油是什么做的
Others: What's cream made of?
Tasha:奶油不是这
Tasha: Cream isn't made like this.
Tasha:么做奶油在冰箱里呢
Tasha: The cream is in the fridge.
Jake:怎么点宝宝随心拼
Jake: How do you order the baby combo?
Jake:我来看看现在麦当劳都有点啥
Jake: Let me check what McDonald's has now.
Jake:铂金奶铁我靠
Jake: Platinum milk iron, wow.
Tasha:好了可以不打了
Tasha: Okay, you can stop beating it.
Tasha:等一下再加最后一个定型的东西就行
Tasha: Just add the last setting ingredient later.
Jake:麦当劳
Jake: McDonald's.
Jake:麦当劳还卖小酥肉啊
Jake: McDonald's even sells crispy pork?
其他人:啊麦当劳这么好吃
Others: Wow, McDonald's is so good.
Jake:我靠是颠覆认知啊
Jake: Wow, this is mind-blowing.
Jake:然后放肉松啊
Jake: And they add pork floss?
Jake:这什么东西啊
Jake: What is this?
Jake:喝了啥小苏打呃
Jake: What did you drink, baking soda?
Jake:差不多大苏打呵呵
Jake: Almost like big baking soda, haha.
其他人:已经厌倦
Others: Already tired of it.
Tasha:好再充分搅拌一下就OK了
Tasha: Alright, just mix it well and it's done.
Tasha:打发到不能再变大
Tasha: Beat it until it can't get any bigger.
Tasha:一直打一直打
Tasha: Keep beating, keep beating.
Tasha:打到他不会再变大
Tasha: Beat until it can't get any bigger.
其他人:他已经变大了
Others: It already got bigger.
Tasha:你他有没有变大嘛
Tasha: Did it get bigger or not?
Tasha:你说蛋清
Tasha: I mean the egg whites.
Shure: 点不了吧
Shure: Can't order it, right?
Shure: 这是到店取餐
Shure: It's for pickup only.
Jake:那他他准备
Jake: Then they should prepare it.
Jake:师傅准备找个跑腿
Jake: Master is looking for someone to run errands.
其他人:离多远我们过去
Others: How far is it? We'll go over.
Jake:2.4公里
Jake: 2.4 kilometers.
Jake:也不是不行
Jake: It's not impossible.
Tasha:打发到你觉得不能再变大的位置
Tasha: Just spread it to the point where it can't get any bigger.
Tasha:就OK了
Tasha: Then it's okay.
Tasha:你跟我来撕一下这个纸
Tasha: Come with me to tear this paper.
Tasha:这里有这个
Tasha: There's this here.
Tasha:不要了
Tasha: Don't need it.
其他人:随你蛋黄和蛋白分开加的剂
Others: Mix the egg yolk and egg white separately with the agent.
Tasha:呃
Tasha: Uh...
Tasha:分开家的意义是
Tasha: What's the point of separating them?
其他人:你的蛋白掺着蛋黄没办法给他打营养
Others: If the egg white is mixed with the yolk, you can't beat it for nutrition.
其他人:但你可以一块打
Others: But you can beat them together.
其他人:不行不可以一块打
Others: No, you can't beat them together.
其他人:就是只有蛋白和蛋白打鸡蛋的做法
Others: You should only beat egg white with egg white when making eggs.
Tasha:双击
Tasha: Double-click.
Jake:接人呢够了
Jake: Picking up people, that's enough.
Jake:勾人呢啊勾了
Jake: Hooking people, yeah, hooked.
Shure: 勾
Shure: Hook.
Shure: 是不是睡着了勾
Shure: Fell asleep while hooking?
Jake:来师傅坐
Jake: Come on, master, sit.
Jake:师傅坐师傅坐
Jake: Master, sit, master, sit.
Tasha:不对
Tasha: No, that's not right.
Tasha:不对劲
Tasha: Something's off.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:我看你不对劲
Jake: I think you're off.
Jake:看你不对劲
Jake: You seem off.
其他人:太稀了是吗
Others: Too thin, right?
其他人:对确实太稀了
Others: Yeah, it's definitely too thin.
其他人:为什么这么稀
Others: Why is it so thin?
其他人:你水加多了
Others: You added too much water.
Tasha:没有不对
Tasha: No, that's not right.
Jake:那怎么办呢
Jake: So what should we do?
其他人:主要是你打的手法不对
Others: Mainly, your technique is wrong.
其他人:到了
Others: There, it's done.
Tasha:继续打吧
Tasha: Keep beating it.
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake:打反了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Beat it backwards, hahaha.
Jake:那还能怎么回事啊
Jake: What else could it be?
Jake:师傅为啥呀
Jake: Master, why?
Tasha:不知道吧
Tasha: Don't know, right?
其他人:你是不是淀粉多少
Others: Do you have too much starch?
Jake:你知道Revere吗
Jake: Do you know Revere?
Jake:就是说不对你就不行
Jake: I mean if it's not right, it's not good.
Tasha:算了稀了加粉
Tasha: Forget it, dilute it and add more powder.
Jake:哈哈哈no more
Jake: Hahaha no more.
Tasha:粉了加干了加加水
Tasha: Add powder, then dry, then add water.
其他人:但是Revere就没有这么好哦
Others: But Revere isn't that good though.
Jake:不会告诉你要加什么
Jake: It won't tell you what to add.
Jake:下一个不适合这个就好
Jake: Just the next one, not suitable for this.
Jake:这个这个这个真会写
Jake: This, this, this one I can really write.
Jake:这我真会写
Jake: This one I can really write.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:我也要一个这个
Tasha: I want one of these too.
Jake:我觉得你这个更适合
Jake: I think this suits you better.
Jake:哈哈哈AC芭提比
Jake: Hahaha AC party B.
Jake:这样哈哈哈
Jake: Like this, hahaha.
Lucia:砍
Lucia: Cut.
Shure: 好了好了好了他队在干活
Shure: Alright, alright, alright, their team is working.
Jake:他干嘛呢
Jake: What is he doing?
Jake:他干活呢
Jake: He's working.
Jake:好嘞我草你
Jake: Okay, damn you.
其他人:我操逆天了
Others: Damn, this is crazy.
Jake:天啊QBZ我草上坡塔了
Jake: Oh my God, QBZ, damn, climbing the tower.
其他人:我真扯到波塔了
Others: I really reached the tower.
Shure: 吓了半天没收到我操
Shure: Scared for a long time, didn't receive a damn thing.
Jake:你们公共区域在哪啊
Jake: Where's your common area?
其他人:公共区域应该在台湾区那个什么Patro
Others: The common area should be in the Taiwan area, something like Patro.
Jake:那你
Jake: Then you...
Jake:那你弄过来呗
Jake: Then you bring it over.
其他人:我已经忘了康大该怎么软硬我怎么来
Others: I've already forgotten how to deal with Kang Da, how to do it.
Jake:就直接copy过去
Jake: Just copy it directly.
Jake:直接copy一个软件啊remove
Jake: Just copy a software, remove.
Jake:你点了吗
Jake: Did you click it?
Shure: 没点呢
Shure: Haven't clicked it yet.
Jake:没点好嘞
Jake: Haven't clicked it, okay.
Tasha:没关系我看他们用除湿机要打5分钟
Tasha: It's okay, I saw them use a dehumidifier for 5 minutes.
Tasha:这种手抽机的话可能要打个10分钟吧
Tasha: This kind of manual dehumidifier might take 10 minutes.
Jake:你坐着打吧
Jake: You can beat it while sitting.
Jake:要不抱着打吧
Jake: Or hold it and beat it.
Jake:好 10分钟之后见
Jake: Alright, see you in 10 minutes.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia:休息一下马上回来
Lucia: Let's take a short break and be right back.
Lucia:好我们可以卡了哈
Lucia: Okay, we can cut here.
Tasha:这个状态是很不对的
Tasha: This state is not right.
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Lucia:哈
Lucia: Huh?
Tasha:如果实在不行
Tasha: If it really doesn't work...
Lucia:啊这是你说要放桌子上那个香薰
Lucia: Ah, this is the aroma diffuser you said to put on the table.
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Tasha:那就加面粉吧
Tasha: Then just add some flour.
其他人:你可以再加点啊
Others: You can add a bit more.
其他人:再稍微加一点
Others: Just a little more.
再看一看吧
Others: Let's take another look.
其他人:水或者什么加太多
Others: Too much water or something.
其他人:什么都没加多呀
Others: Nothing was added too much.
其他人:不是每个都各各多了一克
Others: Not every one weighs an extra gram.
Tasha:你再说每个多一克就会影响这么大
Tasha: You’re saying an extra gram for each would make such a big difference?
其他人:你看现在是不是稍微熟
Others: Look, is it a bit more cooked now?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:买几个弹弓过来玩
Jake: Let's buy some slingshots to play with.
Lucia:弹弓过来
Lucia: Slingshots?
Jake:因为很多是石子哦
Jake: Because many of them are stones, you know.
Jake:砸玻璃哈哈哈哈
Jake: We can smash windows, hahaha.
Shure: 录着呢啊
Shure: It's recording.
Shure: 录着呢
Shure: 都都给你录下来了
Shure: It's all being recorded.
Jake:看看看哪位邻居的玻璃比较脆
Jake: Let's see which neighbor's window is more fragile.
Lucia:不是他们不会没娶我了吧
Lucia: They wouldn't have married me, right?
Jake:啊那你你的号再给他们说一下吧
Jake: Ah, then you should give them your number again.
Lucia:我没有看到有我的呀
Lucia: I didn’t see mine there.
Shure: 他有一些好像他说是虚拟号然后没有
Shure: He said some are virtual numbers and not real.
Jake:写的名字
Jake: The written name.
Jake:是你的名字吗
Jake: Is it your name?
Lucia:嗯我写的名字是朱先生
Lucia: Yeah, I wrote Mr. Zhu.
Jake:哈哈你的皮肤
Jake: Haha, your skin.
Lucia:对我觉得他好像
Lucia: Yeah, I think he seems...
Lucia:我觉得他没有
Lucia: I don't think he did.
Lucia:不会忘了吧
Lucia: He didn't forget, did he?
Lucia:靠那我再进去看一眼
Lucia: Oh no, I'll go in and check again.
Lucia:不会吧不会吧不会吧
Lucia: No way, no way, no way.
Jake:不会吧不会吧
Jake: No way, no way.
Jake:飞机
Jake: Plane.
Jake:no
Jake: No.
Jake:这个角度
Jake: This angle.
Shure: 不能瞎看了这边
Shure: We can't look around aimlessly here.
Jake:看我哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Look at me, hahaha.
Shure: 哇你娘哈哈哈
Shure: Wow, damn, hahaha.
Shure: 徒手搓核弹了是吧
Shure: Are you rubbing a nuclear bomb with your bare hands?
Lucia:真的我觉得他
Lucia: Really, I think he...
Jake:去那边问一下吧
Jake: Go ask over there.
Jake:什么外面好凉快
Jake: Why is it so cool outside?
Jake:确实啊每天都是这样
Jake: Seriously, it's like this every day.
Jake:玩球下不来了
Jake: Playing ball and can't come down.
Tasha:还有人没点吗
Tasha: Has everyone ordered?
Jake:还有人没点吗
Jake: Has everyone ordered?
Jake:我来你你
Jake: I'll do it, you, you...
Tasha:你你哦
Tasha: You, you, oh.
Tasha:呃
Tasha: Uh...
Jake:哈哈你是谁
Jake: Haha, who are you?
Jake:哈哈哈我是谁哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, who am I, haha.
Tasha:我我是谁
Tasha: Who am I?
Tasha:我没转头
Tasha: I didn't turn my head.
Shure: 要不我那有450你先对付用着
Shure: Or I have 450, you can use it for now.
其他人:你会做吗
Others: Can you do it?
Shure: 不是点点点点点外卖
Shure: No, just order delivery.
其他人:那个在在啊
Others: That one, it's there.
Shure: 啊那呢那呢
Shure: Ah, where is it?
其他人:那那那是在薛明主那还是在孟威尔那
Others: That, is it with Xue Mingzhu or with Meng Weier?
Shure: 那呢
Shure: Where is it?
Jake:对他也在点了
Jake: Yeah, he's ordering too.
Jake:是越打越稀吗
Jake: Is it getting thinner?
其他人:好像不是
Others: Doesn't seem like it.
其他人:还是稍微稠了一点
Others: It's getting a bit thicker.
其他人:哦但稠的不多
Others: Oh, but not much thicker.
其他人:这效果没有那么显
Others: The effect isn't that obvious.
Jake:我靠什么东西
Jake: Damn, what is this?
Jake:呃还行吧
Jake: Uh, it's okay.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: No big problem.
其他人:鸡蛋坏了是不是
Others: Is the egg spoiled?
其他人:鸡蛋不对
Others: The egg is not right.
Jake:味对吧
Jake: The taste is right, isn't it?
其他人:味是对的
Others: The taste is right.
Jake:那没问题
Jake: Then no problem.
Jake:对啊为什么这么香
Jake: Yeah, why does it smell so good?
Jake:那坏蛋不是这味
Jake: A spoiled egg wouldn't smell like this.
其他人:因为你那个就是冻的时间不够长
Others: Because you didn't freeze it long enough.
其他人:就蛋清
Others: Just the egg white.
Tasha:我感觉那样打出来是对的
Tasha: I feel like it's right when you beat it like that.
其他人:哪样打出来是对的
Others: Which way is the right way to beat it?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha.
Shure: 他他说
Shure: He said...
Shure: 晚上在这提bug岂不是非常的舒适
Shure: Isn't it super comfortable to bring up bugs here at night?
Shure: 我说有没有可能你在这坐着更舒适呢
Shure: I mean, wouldn't it be more comfortable to sit here?
Jake:哈哈哈反思
Jake: Hahaha, reflection.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人:我要反思
Others: I need to reflect.
其他人:我是爱反思的中国人
Others: I am a reflective Chinese person.
Tasha:对
Tasha: Right.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Shure: 喂你好
Shure: Hello, hi.
Jake:群里问问吧
Jake: Ask in the group.
Lucia:我发了一个不知道他们看到没
Lucia: I sent something, not sure if they saw it.
Jake:发了哈
Jake: You sent it, huh.
其他人:好嘞安慕希菠萝酸奶麦旋风
Others: Alright, Anmuxi pineapple yogurt McFlurry.
其他人:我靠这个看着就想吃
Others: Wow, this looks so appetizing.
Jake:买一赠一了
Jake: Buy one, get one free.
Jake:甜点不能太多
Jake: Can't have too many sweets.
Jake:就这个看着给外国人震慑一下
Jake: Just show this to impress foreigners.
Jake:已经搬家了呀
Jake: Already moved, huh.
Jake:对我我已经点了两个了
Jake: Yeah, I've already ordered two.
Jake:我已经点了第二份搬家了
Jake: I've already ordered the second one, moved.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:玉米淀粉用可可塔塔粉代替了呀
Tasha: Replaced corn starch with cream of tartar.
Jake:哇一模一样
Jake: Wow, exactly the same.
Jake:哈哈哈太可怕了
Jake: Hahaha, that's so scary!
Tasha:太可怕了
Tasha: So scary!
Tasha:那我们找个容器把它放进去开始烤吧
Tasha: Let's find a container and start baking it.
Jake:就直接烤稀的了是吧
Jake: So we're just baking it as it is, right?
Tasha:麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Jake:哦好吃了
Jake: Oh, it's delicious.
其他人:好吃了
Tasha:麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Shure: 慢点慢点慢点慢点
Shure: Slow down, slow down, slow down.
Jake:哎是是不快他很难变快
Jake: Hey, if it's not fast, it's hard to make it fast.
Jake:Sakira是一首歌是吧
Jake: Sakira is a song, right?
其他人:啊不是就是龙舌兰
Others: Ah, no, it's just tequila.
Jake:就是有一首歌
Jake: But there's a song.
Shure: 抹黑错那是
Shure: You're confusing it.
Jake:不是不是也是一首歌
Jake: No, no, it's also a song.
Tasha:这个托呢
Tasha: What about this tray?
其他人:应该还有谁
Others: There should be another one.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
其他人:没点吗
Others: Didn't you order?
Jake:你们点过
Jake: Did you order?
Shure: 都点过了吧谁没点
Shure: Everyone has ordered, right? Who hasn't?
Tasha:这个的托呢
Tasha: What about this tray?
Jake:托
Jake: Tray.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha:好了你不知道在哪
Tasha: Okay, you don't know where it is.
Jake:我确实不知道在哪
Jake: I really don't know where it is.
其他人:加热的味道
Others: The smell of heating.
Jake:烤箱预热预热中
Jake: The oven is preheating.
其他人:你鼻子非常的敏感
Others: Your nose is very sensitive.
Jake:这是鼻子干的事吧哈哈哈
Jake: Does it have anything to do with the nose? Hahaha.
Tasha:没事没事没事找个托我们开始加热吧
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay, find a tray and let's start heating.
Jake:托找不到找不着
Jake: Can't find the tray.
Jake:托是在这里头吗
Jake: Is the tray in here?
Tasha:那那怎么办呢
Tasha: Then what should we do?
Jake:是在这里头
Jake: It's in here.
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Tasha:是在这里头吗
Tasha: Is it in here?
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Tasha:搁哪呢
Tasha: Where is it?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha:你翻一翻呀
Tasha: Flip through it!
Tasha:扒拉扒拉呀
Tasha: Flip it, flip it.
Tasha:哇靠哈哈
Tasha: Oh my gosh, haha.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Ahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈还还好还好皮厚
Jake: Haha, it's alright, it's alright, the skin is thick.
Jake:我靠哈哈
Jake: Oh man, haha.
Jake:我靠师傅直接一刀
Jake: Wow, the master just did it with one cut.
Jake:哈哈哈师傅刀我靠
Jake: Haha, the master's knife skills, wow.
Jake:直接抽我一刀
Jake: He just gave me one cut.
Jake:砍一刀
Jake: A single cut.
Jake:砍一刀还好还好皮厚
Jake: One cut, it's alright, the skin is thick.
Alice:没有确实没
Alice: No, there's really no...
Tasha:没有怎么办
Tasha: What if there's none?
其他人:刀太炖了好烫
Others: The knife is too soft, it's too hot.
Jake:哈哈哈没有直接倒进去
Jake: Haha, just pour it in directly.
其他人:没有直接倒进去
Others: Just pour it in directly.
Tasha:不行
Tasha: No way.
其他人:拿手固定呗
Others: Hold it in place with your hand.
Jake:那因为手也放在烤箱里了
Jake: But the hand is also in the oven.
Katrina: 好香啊
Katrina: Smells so good.
Katrina: 不是是那个
Katrina: No, it's that one.
Jake:这
Jake: This one.
Tasha:这不是鸡蛋的问题吧
Tasha: It's not about the egg, is it?
Jake:找到了这算没有
Jake: Found it, does this count?
其他人:那是哪个香
Others: Which one smells good?
Tasha:没有
Tasha: No.
Katrina: 再待两天
Katrina: Stay for two more days.
Katrina: 我完蛋了哈哈
Katrina: I'm doomed, haha.
Jake:哈哈一个批房啊
Jake: Haha, a batch room.
Jake:啊这是一个批房啊
Jake: Ah, this is a batch room.
Jake:进来的人一定是批人
Jake: Everyone who comes in is a batch.
Katrina: 嗯我要完蛋了
Katrina: Hmm, I'm doomed.
Jake:点完了都点完了
Jake: Finished ordering, all done.
Jake:都点了我还没点
Jake: Everyone ordered, I haven't ordered yet.
Katrina: 我还没点呢
Katrina: I haven't ordered yet.
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:你选哪一個
Jake: Which one are you choosing?
Jake:加一看你选哪一个加1
Jake: Add one, let's see which one you add.
Tasha:噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Jake:所以还是没找着是吧
Jake: So we still haven't found it, right?
Jake:不行
Jake: No way.
Jake:哼这包还在这
Jake: Hmph, this bag is still here.
Jake:包还没变过呢
Jake: The bag hasn't changed.
Jake:开始魔法
Jake: Let's start the magic.
Jake:你猜是谁
Jake: Guess who it is?
Tasha:好了洗洗我们下一个吧
Tasha: Alright, let's wash up and move to the next one.
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
Jake:no哈哈哈
Jake: No, hahaha.
其他人:咱们往里面加点那个
Others: Let's add some of that in.
Tasha:那也得出来再加了
Tasha: We should add it after it's done.
Tasha:可以啊你想买
Tasha: Sure, do you want to buy it?
Tasha:买
Tasha: Buy it.
Tasha:真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha:不用戴手套的
Tasha: You don't need to wear gloves.
Tasha:你这么爱吃菠萝吗
Tasha: Do you love eating pineapples that much?
其他人:就是随便加点
Others: Just add some casually.
其他人:加点菠萝然后草莓
Others: Add some pineapple and strawberries.
Jake:主要是看到的菠萝
Jake: Mainly because we saw the pineapple.
Jake:他说看到草莓应该也会加
Jake: He said if he saw strawberries, he would add them too.
Jake:你不得切一切
Jake: You gotta cut them up.
Jake:哎好嘞
Jake: Ah, good.
Tasha:好嘞
Tasha: Good.
其他人:但是我不知道他家烤菜是不是我一样
Others: But I don't know if their roasted dishes are the same as mine.
其他人:用的烤菠萝
Others: Using roasted pineapple.
其他人:是是是
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:火烤啊
Jake: Grilled.
Jake:上火
Jake: On fire.
Tasha:这在哪开啊
Tasha: Where do you open this?
Tasha:拿12个
Tasha: Take twelve.
Jake:哦这边有镊子
Jake: Oh, there are tweezers here.
Tasha:把托找一下行吗
Tasha: Can you find the tray?
Jake:把什么托
Jake: Find what tray?
Tasha:托
Tasha: The tray.
Jake:对我在找托
Jake: Yes, I'm looking for the tray.
其他人:那我就不客气了
Others: Then I won't be polite.
Tasha:这个蛋挞很简单
Tasha: This egg tart is very simple.
Tasha:来个简单的
Tasha: Let's do a simple one.
Tasha:这个我做过好多遍
Tasha: I've made this many times.
Tasha:提拉米苏也做过好多遍
Tasha: I've also made tiramisu many times.
Tasha:这两个不会失败的
Tasha: These two won't fail.
Tasha:还买了一个专业的
Tasha: I also bought a professional one.
Jake:这蓝莓怎么这么丑啊
Jake: Why do these blueberries look so ugly?
Jake:哈哈哈什么呵呵
Jake: Hahaha, what do you mean "heh heh"?
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:教师傅撕保鲜袋
Jake: Teach the master how to tear the cling film.
Tasha:我我我好像学会了
Tasha: I-I-I think I learned it.
Tasha:看你这样操作
Tasha: Watching you do it like this.
Jake:真的没有吗
Jake: Really, there's none left?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Tasha:那天我们明明一起把那个托
Tasha: That day, we clearly put the tray together.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:盘削在这的结果就不见了
Tasha: We placed the tray here, but it disappeared.
Jake:这不合理啊
Jake: This doesn't make sense.
Jake:我来打
Jake: I'll do it.
Jake:你拿这个打
Jake: You use this one.
其他人:我不要这个
Others: I don't want this one.
其他人:打打不开一点
Others: Can you open it a bit more?
Jake:真的
Jake: Really.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 有人要去取快递吗
Katrina: Is anyone going to pick up the package?
Jake:啊他可以现在单独去取吗
Jake: Ah, can he go pick it up himself now?
Lucia:他说他现在忙不过来
Lucia: He said he's too busy right now.
Jake:那
Jake: Then...
Jake:他说让自己取是吧
Jake: He said to get it himself, right?
Tasha:你干嘛带上
Tasha: Why did you bring that?
Jake:因为比较平
Jake: Because it's flat.
Jake:对是吧多好解冻
Jake: Yes, it's much easier to defrost, right?
Tasha:别倒
Tasha: Don't spill it.
Jake:哎呀好冰啊
Jake: Ah, so cold!
Tasha:一二三四五六七八九十
Tasha: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Tasha:1112 好
Tasha: Eleven, twelve, okay.
Tasha:把它拆开就行
Tasha: Just unwrap it.
Jake:哎呀好冰好冰
Jake: Ah, so cold, so cold.
Jake:不行了不行了不行了不行了不行了
Jake: I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't.
Jake:冻坏了冻坏了
Jake: It's frozen, it's frozen.
Jake:哎哟我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
其他人:好冰
Others: So cold.
Jake:就是蛋挞皮放我手上
Jake: Just put the tart shell on my hand.
Jake:蛋挞放在了外边
Jake: The tart was left outside.
其他人:嗯
Others: Hmm.
Jake:找到了
Jake: Found it.
Tasha:点什么还在点吗
Tasha: What are you ordering? Still ordering?
Jake:不不不点了不点了
Jake: No, no, no more ordering.
Tasha:500多块钱怎么吃到500多的
Tasha: How did we spend over 500 bucks?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea.
Tasha:我靠这个人谁
Tasha: Oh my God, who is this person?
Tasha:太过分了
Tasha: This is too much.
Tasha:吃一个77块钱的套餐
Tasha: Someone ate a 77-dollar meal.
Jake:谁呀
Jake: Who?
Tasha:我只吃了那个22块钱的套餐
Tasha: I only had the 22-dollar meal.
Jake:揪出来揪出来
Jake: Find out who it was.
Tasha:揪出来揪出来
Tasha: Find out who it was.
Tasha:揪出来我只吃了27块钱
Tasha: Find out, I only had 27 dollars.
Tasha:他吃七十几
Tasha: Someone else ate 70-something.
Jake:没关系分掉
Jake: It's okay, we'll split it.
Jake:瓜分掉
Jake: Split it up.
Jake:到时候大家盲选好吧
Jake: Everyone just choose blindly, alright?
Jake:我就在这拖着嘛
Jake: I'll just drag it here.
Tasha:你把这个麦津会员开了是吗
Tasha: Did you activate the membership for Mai Jin?
Jake:我我我没动他
Jake: I didn't touch it.
Tasha:因为他写他只要19块钱
Tasha: Because it says it only costs 19 bucks.
Tasha:但他这一单可以减37块5
Tasha: But this order can save 37.5 bucks.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:我靠怎么会买到56068块钱
Tasha: How did it end up being 56068 bucks?
Jake:咱总共9个
Jake: We have 9 people in total.
Alice:是不是有的套餐那个啥
Alice: Could it be some of the meals...
Jake:咱总共10个人
Jake: We have 10 people in total.
Alice:超过一份就原价了还是怎么样
Alice: If you order more than one, is it full price or what?
Tasha:太离谱了
Tasha: This is ridiculous.
Jake:9个人吗
Jake: 9 people?
Tasha:我们是选这个餐厅吗
Tasha: Did we choose this restaurant?
Tasha:哦好吧
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:因为撤嗯
Jake: Because we canceled, right?
Tasha:是选这个餐厅
Tasha: We chose this restaurant.
Jake:67899个哦
Jake: 67899 of us, oh.
Jake:这么回事哦
Jake: That's how it is, huh.
Jake:你们做的
Jake: You guys did it.
Jake:哦行吧
Jake: Oh, alright.
Jake:你们做的
Jake: You guys did it.
Tasha:568块钱啊
Tasha: 568 yuan, huh
Jake:好 9个9个
Jake: Okay, nine of them, nine.
Jake:点了500多
Jake: Ordered over 500.
Jake:也行吧合理合理
Jake: That's okay, reasonable, reasonable.
Jake:10刀嘛
Jake: Ten bucks each.
Jake:一人10刀嘛
Jake: Ten bucks per person.
Katrina: 风舌兰没买到那个
Katrina: Couldn't get that orchid.
Jake:嗯买到了哎
Jake: Oh, we got it.
Jake:不是你点到了
Jake: No, you ordered it.
Jake:已经买完了
Jake: It's already bought.
Jake:外卖卖完了
Jake: The delivery is sold out.
其他人:这烤箱还好垃圾
Others: This oven is so trash.
Tasha:这烤箱还垃圾
Tasha: This oven is trash.
Jake:这还特地租的呢
Jake: We even rented it specially.
其他人:相当垃圾
Others: It's quite trash.
Tasha:怎么垃圾了
Tasha: Why is it trash?
其他人:这个门这都不隔热
Others: This door doesn't even insulate heat.
Jake:小米
Jake: Xiaomi.
Tasha:这小米的
Tasha: It's from Xiaomi.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人:他大米他也不行
Others: Even if it's from Dami, it wouldn't work.
Jake:这还挺香
Jake: But it smells quite good.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:可算
Jake: Finally.
Tasha:买可贵了
Tasha: It was so expensive.
Jake:可算拿下去了
Jake: Finally took it down.
Tasha:然后把洗一洗
Tasha: Then wash it.
其他人:这能接着用吗
Others: Can this still be used?
Tasha:不可以接着用了
Tasha: No, it can't be used anymore.
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Others:
Jake:加薯片行吗
Jake: Add some chips, okay?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
其他人:孩子就用这些孩子就用这些
Others: Kids just use these, kids just use these.
Jake:蛋挞加薯片是不是也还行啊
Jake: Egg tarts with chips are not bad, right?
Tasha:可以
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's pretty good.
Tasha:谁把放在这
Tasha: Who put this here?
Jake:我走了
Jake: I'm leaving.
Jake:应该不是我应该不是我应该不是我
Jake: It wasn't me, it wasn't me, it wasn't me.
Jake:因为我没收拾
Jake: Because I didn't clean up.
Jake:哈哈哈应该不是我
Jake: Hahaha, it shouldn't be me.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡我的
Jake: The McDonald's burger is mine.
Jake:切把切了哈
Jake: Cut it, cut it.
Tasha:行我来我来我来擦
Tasha: Okay, I'll do it, I'll clean it.
Jake:我再给我
Jake: I'll give myself...
Jake:再给你们一个芒果的配料
Jake: I'll give you guys another mango ingredient.
其他人:对其实蛋挞里也可以随便加了
Others: Yeah, actually you can add anything to the egg tart.
Tasha:蛋挞上面应该随便加8的蛋挞
Tasha: You can add anything to the egg tart.
Tasha:烤完蛋挞
Tasha: After baking the egg tart.
其他人:蛋挞不会只有一人一个吧
Others: There won't be only one egg tart per person, right?
其他人:还真一人
Others: There really is one per person.
Tasha:12个还真一人
Tasha: 12, one each.
其他人:差不多一个
Others: About one each.
Tasha:一人吃一个还不够吗
Tasha: One each isn't enough?
其他人:我不够行
Others: For me, it's not enough.
Tasha:那你吃两个番茄
Tasha: Then have two tomatoes.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:剩下8个人分两个呵呵
Jake: The remaining 8 people can share two, hehe.
Tasha:你真想吃的话咱们就烤24个
Tasha: If you really want to eat them, we'll bake 24.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
其他人:可以吗
Others: Is that okay?
其他人:有没有不甜的
Others: Are there any that aren't sweet?
Tasha:做不甜的
Tasha: Make it not sweet.
Tasha:你吃不甜的
Tasha: Do you eat non-sweet ones?
Tasha:你吃什么甜品
Tasha: What kind of dessert do you eat?
Tasha:你想吃不甜的
Tasha: You want to eat non-sweet ones?
Jake:呵呵是
Jake: Hehe, yes.
Tasha:那我们就做个低糖的吧
Tasha: Then let's make a low-sugar one.
Jake:找不到吗
Jake: Can't find it?
Tasha:不甜的甜品
Tasha: Non-sweet dessert.
其他人:是中国人对甜品的最高评价
Others: It's the highest praise from Chinese people for a dessert.
Jake:剪刀
Jake: Scissors.
Jake:有很多可以代替剪刀的东西
Jake: There are many things that can replace scissors.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Tasha:对的
Tasha: Right.
Tasha:您说什么都对
Tasha: You're right about everything.
Jake:所以为什么呢
Jake: So why is that?
Jake:为什么不填他就最高评价了
Jake: Why is it that not sweet is the highest praise?
其他人:很不甜比较健康
Others: It's not very sweet, much healthier.
其他人:比较健康
Others: Much healthier.
Jake:那为什么不吃草
Jake: Then why not eat grass?
其他人:就是不甜中
Others: It's just not sweet.
其他人:你们能感感受到
Others: Can you guys feel it?
其他人:这个糖给你带来的愉悦
Others: The joy this sugar brings you.
Jake:哦哇
Jake: Oh wow.
其他人:上海人那么机器真好用
Others: Shanghai people's machines are really good.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Jake:突然好用了
Jake: Suddenly it works well.
Jake:你这配了
Jake: You've matched it.
Jake:你配多久
Jake: How long did you match it?
其他人: 我都在等他好吧
Others: I've been waiting for him, okay.
Tasha:这都擦干了
Tasha: It's all wiped dry.
Tasha:你就放进来你
Tasha: You just put it in.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
Alice:你叫什么
Alice: What's your name?
Alice:就是你是小差吗
Alice: Are you Xiao Chai?
Alice:呃收件名
Alice: Uh, the recipient's name.
Jake:杨鑫鑫是吧
Jake: Yang Xinxin, right?
Jake:杨鑫鑫就是那个鑫鑫
Jake: Yang Xinxin, that Xinxin.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 天空
Shure: The sky.
Alice:我把那个地毯给你
Alice: I'll get you the carpet.
Alice:我说怎么感觉好像跟我印象不太一样
Alice: I thought it felt different from what I remembered.
Lucia:他那几个肯定没取上
Lucia: He definitely didn't pick those up.
Lucia:然后他非跟我说申通这他取了
Lucia: And then he insisted he got them from Shentong.
Lucia:问题这也没有啊
Lucia: But there's nothing here.
Lucia:然后那几个他也没取上
Lucia: And he didn't get those either.
Lucia:然后他非说是
Lucia: Then he insisted it was.
Lucia:然后他非说是驿站弄错了
Lucia: Then he insisted the station made a mistake.
Katrina: 公费买了很多娃娃
Katrina: Bought a lot of dolls with public funds.
其他人:公费娃娃
Others: Public fund dolls.
Jake:公费娃娃
Jake: Public fund dolls.
Shure: 什么公费娃娃
Shure: What's public fund dolls?
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea.
Shure: 他在想什么
Shure: What's he thinking?
Jake:挂着然后我再改版改版
Jake: Hang it and then I'll modify it again.
Jake:没有没啥有
Jake: Nothing, nothing much.
Jake:用的东西
Jake: Things used.
Jake:就是欢迎路亚
Jake: Just welcome Lua.
Lucia:这好像也不是我吧
Lucia: This doesn't seem like it's for me.
Jake:我再改吧我再改改
Jake: I'll change it, I'll change it.
Lucia:我也觉得
Lucia: I think so too.
Lucia:对啊我要爆粗了靠
Lucia: Yeah, I'm about to curse, damn it.
Jake:走我们去
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:我们直接去驿站
Jake: Let's go directly to the station.
Jake:没有小车
Jake: No small car.
Jake:你得走去
Jake: You have to walk.
其他人:草那也可以
Others: Damn, that's fine too.
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Yeah, it's fine.
其他人:可以啊那怎么没有小车
其他人:等一会拿麦当劳的时候一起
Others: Wait until we pick up McDonald's.
其他人:麦当劳肯定不在一个地方啊
Others: McDonald's is definitely not in the same place.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:有他们对
Jake: They are right.
Jake:他们有几个地方
Jake: They have several places.
Jake:但确实
Jake: But indeed.
Jake:哎对啊
Jake: Oh yeah.
Jake:问问问问
Jake: Ask, ask, ask.
Jake:这个师傅那跑腿
Jake: Ask the guy to run errands.
Jake:咱找咱们还是没找
Jake: Should we find him or not?
Lucia:这胶带看起来很像我的
Lucia: This tape looks like mine.
Lucia:但他名字不是我
Lucia: But the name isn't mine.
Lucia:所以我认为应该也不是我
Lucia: So I don't think it's mine.
Jake:小
Jake: Small.
Jake:哪一个
Jake: Which one?
Lucia:对绝对
Lucia: Yeah, definitely.
Lucia:没错我都是猪先生
Lucia: Right, I'm always Mr. Pig.
Jake:张
Jake: Zhang.
Jake:哦你已经分好了
Jake: Oh, you've already sorted it out.
Jake:什么隐
Jake: What hidden?
其他人:就是我记不记得这个道路上全都是隐
Others: Remember this road is full of hidden.
Jake:哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake:搞笑
Jake: Funny.
其他人:我草这个QQ你觉得屌不屌
Others: Damn, do you think this QQ is cool?
其他人:你平时走路掉很多线
Others: You drop a lot of lines while walking.
其他人:为什么定位到地铁口
Others: Why locate to the subway entrance?
其他人:打个场击不用
Others: Don't need to hit a field.
其他人:怎么了
Others: What happened?
Jake:你背后怎么了
Jake: What's up with your back?
Lucia:是这不是
Lucia: Is this it?
Lucia:是他贴的还是你帮他贴的
Lucia: Did he stick it on, or did you help him?
Lucia:我是不是啊哈
Lucia: Am I... Ah ha.
其他人:啊没关系啊
Others: Ah, it's okay.
Jake:谁贴的
Jake: Who stuck it on?
其他人:不知道
Others: No idea.
其他人:感觉只有修硕能干出来这种事情
Others: Feels like something Shure would do.
Lucia:哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 我没有这么自恋
Shure: I'm not that narcissistic.
Jake:行吧几个场面
Jake: Alright, moving on.
Shure: 我每次贴东西都是代表
Shure: Whenever I stick something, it's to mark my stuff.
Shure: 是我的东西才会贴上你
Shure: Only my things get labeled, not others'.
Shure: 不是我的
Shure: It's not mine.
Jake:你是你是
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 你别恶心我
Shure: Don't gross me out.
其他人:181818
Others: 181818.
其他人:记住丢烟头
Others: Remember to throw away the cigarette butt.
Jake:哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: Hahaha, idiot.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:你不说可能还没人录到这个细节
Lucia: If you didn't mention it, no one would have noticed that detail.
Jake:处理视频中逻辑
Jake: Editing the video logic.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈神
Lucia: Hahaha, genius.
Shure: 他昨天在二楼的时候脱光了
Shure: Yesterday, he stripped on the second floor.
Jake:他他他对
Jake: He, he, he, yeah.
Jake:他傍晚时候要想洗澡
Jake: He wanted to take a shower in the evening.
Jake:然后他不知道二楼还在没关
Jake: Then he didn’t know the second floor was still open.
其他人:我就指着上半身
Others: I just pointed at his upper body.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 被摄像头全录下来了
Shure: The camera caught everything.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 还没事那上半身看看
Shure: It's no big deal, just the upper body.
Jake:也就8个摄像头
Jake: Only 8 cameras.
Shure: 怕什么哈哈哈
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha
Shure: 给你360度还原
Shure: I'll give you a 360-degree view.
Shure: 你的骨架
Shure: of your skeleton
Lucia:害怕了
Lucia: I'm scared.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:把我的狗替杀
Lucia: Replace my dog
Jake:我不敢动它不敢动它
Jake: I don't dare touch it, don't dare touch it.
Jake:它咬我
Jake: It will bite me.
其他人:不敢想象在这烧狗晚上得多丑
Others: Can't imagine roasting a dog here at night, how ugly it would be.
其他人:哎我靠
Others: Oh my gosh.
Jake:烤了烤了3个小时
Jake: Roasted for 3 hours.
Jake:没没着火
Jake: Didn't catch fire.
Jake:哈哈哈后悔了
Jake: Hahaha regret it.
其他人:不敢想象在这烧烤得有多少在这烧
Others: Can't imagine how many would roast here.
Lucia:不是那为啥还是
Lucia: No, then why is it still...
Lucia:欢迎欢迎
Lucia: Welcome, welcome.
Lucia:我提亲啊
Lucia: I'm proposing.
Jake:因为这是最后一个
Jake: Because this is the last one.
Jake:我再给你们这群加上
Jake: I'll add this group to you guys.
Lucia:太奇怪了
Lucia: Too weird.
Lucia:能把它关掉吗
Lucia: Can you turn it off?
Jake:哈哈哈我再加几个
Jake: Hahaha I'll add a few more.
Jake:好吧让大家一起尴尬
Jake: Okay, let's all be embarrassed together.
Lucia:对对对大家全都加上去
Lucia: Yes, yes, everyone add on.
Jake:好好好好欢迎欢迎
Jake: Alright, alright, welcome, welcome.
Jake:羞弱抵金是吧
Jake: Humility is gold, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:欢迎羞弱抵
Jake: Welcome to humility.
Lucia:太奇怪了
Lucia: Too weird.
Shure: 我递通好吧
Shure: I'm passing, alright.
Jake:抵通可以可以
Jake: Passing, okay, okay.
Lucia:快关一下
Lucia: Turn it off quickly.
Lucia:杨老师快关一下
Lucia: Jake, turn it off quickly.
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:抵制坏了艾斯克尔又又过不了
Jake: Resisting Esker again, can't pass again.
其他人:坏了艾斯克尔又又过不了
Others: Resisting Esker again, can't pass again.
Jake:抵制什么呀
Jake: What are you resisting?
Jake:你要抵制什么呀哈哈哈
Jake: What are you resisting, hahaha.
Shure: 再说抵制通货膨胀的
Shure: Talking about resisting inflation.
其他人:再说我又要打打打款机了
Others: Talking about hitting the money machine again.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Shure: 通货膨胀可以抵制一下吧
Shure: Can we resist inflation a bit?
Jake:加两个加两个
Jake: Add two more, add two more.
Jake:先加一个求数
Jake: First, add a sum.
Jake:就用你的这个
Jake: Just use yours.
Jake:你你你PPT里面那照片怎么样
Jake: How about the photo in your PPT?
Shure: 什么好
Shure: Which one?
Jake:你PPT
Jake: Your PPT.
其他人:打码的打码
Others: Censored, censored.
Jake:打码的
Jake: Censored.
Shure: 你别打码的了
Shure: Don't censor it.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia:他有可能也落下了
Lucia: He might have missed it too.
Lucia:他把我好多快递都落下了
Lucia: He missed many of my packages.
Katrina: no
Katrina: No.
Lucia:然后他还非说他取了
Lucia: And he insisted he picked them up.
Lucia:啊哪个哪个女生
Lucia: Ah, which girl?
Jake:他他不知道
Jake: He, he doesn't know.
Jake:群里不知道是什么人
Jake: No one in the group knows who it is.
Lucia:对群里不知道是谁
Lucia: Yeah, no one in the group knows.
其他人:我靠这是什么
Others: Whoa, what is this?
其他人:我靠这么帅
Others: Whoa, so handsome.
Lucia:有一个申通他百分百没取
Lucia: There's one from Shentong that he definitely didn't pick up.
Jake:走我们去取
Jake: Let's go pick it up.
其他人:走走let's go
Others: Let's go, let's go.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Haha, no, no.
其他人:let's go
Others: Let's go.
Lucia:那也可以先去取然后行
Lucia: We can go pick it up first, then it's fine.
Jake:我问一下
Jake: I'll ask.
Jake:我先问一下这个你的胶到了吗
Jake: I'll ask if your glue arrived.
Alice:你的胶到了吗
Alice: Did your glue arrive?
Lucia:我的胶他没给我取
Lucia: He didn't pick up my glue.
Lucia:那个那个取快递的那个
Lucia: The person who picks up the packages.
Jake:嗯有跑腿是吧
Jake: Hmm, there's a runner service, right?
Tasha:点过啦跑腿
Tasha: Yes, I ordered a runner.
Jake:那我们去取快递
Jake: Then let's go pick up the package.
其他人:我靠我一会要看看
Others: Whoa, I need to see it later.
其他人:如果好如果好看的话我也要买一个
Others: If it's good, I'll buy one too.
Jake:走走走取快递去
Jake: Let's go, let's go pick up the package.
其他人:一一定一定
Others: Definitely, definitely.
其他人:一会要让我看那个小狐狸
Others: Show me the little fox later.
Katrina: 我找找真的
Katrina: I'll look for it, really.
其他人:一定要让我看看
Others: You have to show me.
Katrina: 没看见所有快递都在这吗
Katrina: Can't you see all the packages are here?
其他人:如果好看的话我买的快递都在这吗
Others: If it's good, are all my packages here?
其他人:啊不肯定不全
Others: Ah, definitely not all of them.
其他人:应该不全
Others: Probably not all.
Jake:就是还没取呗
Jake: Just haven't been picked up yet.
Lucia:不全可百分百不全
Lucia: Not all, definitely not all.
Jake:百分百不全
Jake: Definitely not all.
其他人:你的手机上能看到哪些快递群
Others: Can you see which packages on your phone?
Lucia:哎这好可爱
Lucia: Oh, this is so cute.
Jake:我试试
Jake: Let me try.
Lucia:可可爱爱
Lucia: So cute.
其他人:像是我女朋友喜欢的东西这
Others: Looks like something my girlfriend would like.
Jake:这摩的呵呵呵还挺可爱的这摩的
Jake: This scooter, haha, it's actually pretty cute, this scooter.
Katrina: 哦没取的就没签收
Katrina: Oh, the uncollected ones haven't been signed for.
Jake:对摩的然后这个
Jake: Yeah, the scooter, and then this.
Jake:就
Jake: Just...
Jake:新加坡夜里面就有那个很大声音的
Jake: In Singapore at night, there's that loud noise.
Jake:那个摩的
Jake: That scooter.
Jake:对切了之后
Jake: Yeah, after it was modified.
Jake:对然后换成他
Jake: Yeah, then changed it.
Jake:就是给他配了个围巾
Jake: And gave it a scarf.
Lucia:没事反正老板早晚要知道的
Lucia: It's okay, the boss will find out sooner or later.
Jake:啥呀这个这是围巾啊
Jake: What, this? This is a scarf?
Jake:这是围巾啊
Jake: This is a scarf?
Katrina: 没有没有这只是围巾的价格
Katrina: No, no, this is just the price of the scarf.
其他人:哈哈哈狐狸的价格你就别看了
Others: Hahaha, don't even look at the price of the fox.
其他人:反正也不是你出钱
Others: It's not your money anyway.
Jake:哈哈哈我看看我看看
Jake: Hahaha, let me see, let me see.
Katrina: 预算拉满
Katrina: Budget maxed out.
其他人:那个狐狸我感觉得200200加一个围巾
Others: That fox, I feel like it's 200 plus a scarf.
Katrina: 200加一个围巾
Katrina: 200 plus a scarf.
Jake:我看看围巾是啥
Jake: Let me see what the scarf is.
Katrina: 看看围巾是啥
Katrina: Check out the scarf.
Katrina: 围巾是绿色毛茸茸手工做的
Katrina: The scarf is green, fluffy, and handmade.
其他人:一会先买家秀一下
Others: Let's show the buyer first.
其他人:如果好我也买一个
Others: If it's good, I'll buy one too.
其他人:卧槽这个这个
Others: Whoa, this, this.
其他人:明天就是一个进货的阶段
Others: Tomorrow is a restocking phase.
Jake:对对明天
Jake: Yes, tomorrow.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Jake:明天每人带个眼镜
Jake: Everyone bring glasses tomorrow.
Jake:然后你们就对
Jake: And then you guys...
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:去拿去拿
Jake: Go get it, go get it.
Jake:走走咱俩咋去
Jake: Let's go, how should we get there?
其他人:咱俩咋去
Others: How should we get there?
Jake:走去
Jake: Let's walk.
其他人:走过去很远
Others: Walking is too far.
Jake:那怎么办
Jake: So what do we do?
Jake:有共享单车吗
Jake: Are there shared bikes?
Jake:打车
Jake: Let's take a cab.
Lucia:我看一眼那个京东应该是我的吧
Lucia: Let me check, that JD package should be mine.
Jake:开车开开车方便吗
Jake: Is it convenient to drive?
Jake:开车方便去吗
Jake: Is it convenient to drive there?
Jake:跟牛帅说一下
Jake: Let Nicous know.
Jake:开牛帅车过去
Jake: Let's take Nicous' car.
Jake:咱没有走
Jake: We have no other way.
Jake:走大路走大路前点无法自拔
Jake: Let's take the main road, the main road...
其他人:沉迷甜点无法自拔
Others: Addicted to desserts, can't get enough.
其他人:对啊
Others: Yeah.
Shure: 虽然是个老的
Shure: Even though it's old...
Shure: 但是也是奔驰e呢
Shure: It's still a Mercedes E-Class.
Katrina: 天呐我们这几天有100多个快递吧
Katrina: Oh my God, we have over 100 packages these days.
Jake:哈哈哈得有得有得有
Jake: Haha, yeah, we do, we do.
Katrina: 感觉有每个人十几个
Katrina: Feels like each person has a dozen.
Katrina: 我有十几个
Katrina: I have a dozen.
Jake:我有20多个
Jake: I have over 20.
Katrina: 我有20多个
Katrina: I have over 20.
Katrina: 你也有20多个
Katrina: You have over 20 too?
Jake:没有我我这些东西很多的
Jake: No, I just have a lot of stuff.
Shure: 你看我给你最省
Shure: See, I saved the most for you.
Shure: 我就两个
Shure: I only have two.
Jake:麦当劳谢谢您
Jake: McDonald's, thank you.
Shure: 给你省了多少经费
Shure: See how much budget I saved for you.
Tasha:我选择这里
Tasha: I'll choose here.
其他人:那我们直接走推荐
Others: Then let's go directly.
Tasha:走去哪里
Tasha: Where are we going?
Jake:驿站这谁
Jake: Who's at the station?
其他人:麦当劳就一公里还开车去麦
Others: McDonald's is just a kilometer away, and you want to drive there?
Tasha:麦当劳送到门口了
Tasha: McDonald's delivers to the door.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:咱是取快递
Jake: We're picking up a package.
Jake:咱是要取快递
Jake: We're here to pick up a package.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:确实这
Jake: Seriously, this...
其他人:这谁贴的
Others: Who posted this?
其他人:不知道刘帅贴的吧
Others: Don't know, maybe Choiszt did?
其他人:啥呀
Others: What?
其他人:不是我不一直在这呆着
Others: Not me, I've been here the whole time.
Jake:不是我贴的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Katrina: 不是你不是你吗
Katrina: Wasn't it you?
Jake:不是你吗
Jake: Wasn't it you?
Katrina: 调监控
Katrina: Check the security footage.
Tasha:鸡蛋羹不得搁
Tasha: The steamed egg should be...
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha:搁鸡蛋进去
Tasha: ...put an egg in it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:挖掘三尺
Jake: Dig deep.
Jake:你想想你想想
Jake: Think about it.
Jake:你贴的时候有没有戴眼镜
Jake: Were you wearing glasses when you posted it?
Lucia:原来你不知道
Lucia: So you didn't know.
Jake:不知道
Jake: Didn't know.
Jake:你你想想贴的时候戴没戴眼镜
Jake: Think about it, were you wearing glasses when you posted it?
Shure: 不如啊
Shure: Maybe not.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 贴啥
Shure: What did you post?
Jake:走走走哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, let's go. Hahaha.
Shure: 这是我我们老的队名
Shure: This is our old team name.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:那根线是谁的呀
Jake: Whose cable is that?
Shure: 上面写名了应该
Shure: It should have a name on it.
Shure: 刘宇轩
Shure: Liu Yuxuan.
Shure: 线怎么自己不接个好的呢
Shure: Why didn't he connect it properly?
Jake:S1C04吗
Jake: Is it S1C04?
Jake:是吗你是C04吗
Jake: Is it you, C04?
Katrina: 我不记得我是谁谁谁
Katrina: I don't remember who I am.
Jake:是那就C04吧
Jake: If it is, then it's C04.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake:你是C01 C02啊
Jake: Are you C01 or C02?
Jake:C03
Jake: C03
Jake:他先扫的你后扫的你就是C04
Jake: He scanned first, you scanned later, so you're C04.
Lucia:所以呢这个号有什么用吗
Lucia: So, what's the use of this number?
Jake:就是模型的代号啊
Jake: It's the model's code.
Shure: 这是我们的数字生命的代号
Shure: It's the code for our digital life.
Jake:是的模型3D
Jake: Yes, the 3D model.
Shure: 我们每个人都扫了一个3D的模
Shure: Each of us scanned a 3D model.
Jake:就是你的那个
Jake: It's yours.
Jake:你你你当年的那个东西
Jake: That thing from back then.
Jake:走发
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake:个人
Jake: Personal.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
其他人:我觉得那个还是很很好用的
Others: I think that was really useful.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
其他人:虽然文件比较大
Others: Though the file is quite large.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure:  （歌词）听罢新征程号角吹响
Shure: (Lyrics) The new journey horn has sounded.
Shure: （歌词）将军目标召唤在前方
Shure: (Lyrics) The general's target is ahead.
Jake:没有小车哎
Jake: No small car, huh?
Jake:问问可能
Jake: Ask, maybe.
Jake:不是我们这个院子的
Jake: It's not from our yard.
Jake:不是我们这院子的
Jake:试试试试问问
Jake: Try, try asking.
Jake:别走有步
Jake: Don't go, there's a step.
Jake:您您是佑佑的院子吗
Jake: Are you from Yoyo's yard?
（歌词）啊什么事
(Lyrics) Ah, what's the matter?
Jake:我们想取快递啊
Jake: We want to pick up a package.
（歌词）咱们那个车
(Lyrics) Our car.
（歌词）现在我要去那个送东西啊
(Lyrics) Now I need to deliver something.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:送不了好
Jake: Can't deliver well.
（歌词）嗯咱们那个按着那个导航
(Lyrics) Follow the navigation.
（歌词）然后那个咱自己取一下
(Lyrics) Then pick it up ourselves.
（歌词）那个车也在拉东西
(Lyrics) The car is also carrying stuff.
Jake:好我们能租
Jake: Okay, we can rent.
Jake:嗯我们走吧
Jake: Hmm, let's go.
Shure: 我们可以GTA了f
Shure: We can GTA now, press F.
Jake:哈哈哈摁f
Jake: Hahaha, press F.
Jake:F键
Jake: F key.
Shure: 键进入载具
Shure: Press the key to enter the vehicle.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake:哈哈偷我车是不会的吧
Jake: Hahaha, you won't steal my car, right?
Shure: 一般偷个车不会的吧
Shure: Generally, stealing a car is unlikely.
其他人:偷车在在洛洛洛圣都是不会机智
Others: Stealing cars in Los Santos is not smart.
其他人:但在别的地方就不一定
Others: But in other places, maybe.
其他人:感觉路上路
Others: Feels like on the road...
其他人:我们如果只偷个车的话
Others: If we just steal a car...
其他人:出一嗨再往从天上掉个坦克
Others: Suddenly a tank might drop from the sky.
其他人:哈哈哈我记得有那个
Others: Hahaha, I remember there's that...
其他人:有一个什么暗语
Others: There's some sort of code.
其他人:就是什么输一输一个英文单词
Others: Just enter an English word and...
其他人:然后跟什么无伤跑的巨帅
Others: Then you can run without getting hurt, super cool.
其他人:子弹无限
Others: Infinite bullets.
Jake:对哎
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:咱有导航吗
Jake: Do we have GPS?
Shure: 咱没导航
Shure: We don't have GPS.
Jake:哈哈哈傻子
Jake: Hahaha, idiot.
Shure: 咱在这瞎瞎鸡走什么呢哈
Shure: We're just wandering around aimlessly, huh?
Jake:哈哈哈等会等会等会等会
Jake: Hahaha, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Jake:这真打GT啊
Jake: Are we really playing GTA?
Jake:难走哈哈哈
Jake: It's so hard, hahaha.
Shure: 当然当然
Shure: Of course, of course.
Shure: 你没戴眼镜没事
Shure: You didn't wear glasses, it's fine.
Katrina: 你没戴眼镜菜鸟吗
Katrina: You didn't wear glasses, newbie?
其他人:我看飞机应该没什么吧
Others: I think the plane should be fine.
Shure: 我看飞机应该没事吧
Shure: I think the plane should be fine.
Jake:你看飞机没什么
Jake: You think the plane is fine.
Shure: 对我们看不行
Shure: Yeah, we can't see it.
其他人:为什么谁知道的
Others: Why? Who knows?
Jake:是啥呀对
Jake: What is it? Yeah.
Shure: 谁知道这眼镜戴不戴透视
Shure: Who knows if these glasses are x-ray.
Jake:透视哈
Jake: X-ray, huh.
Shure: 哈哈哈麦塔告诉我们是没戴那
Shure: Hahaha, Meta told us it's not wearing them.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:如果说是那个菜鸟的话
Lucia: If you're talking about a newbie...
Shure: 谁知道杨老板知道多些呢
Shure: Who knows, Jake knows more, right?
Lucia:好像是这个方向
Lucia: Seems like it's this direction.
Lucia:然后这样然后这样然后这样然后这样
Lucia: And like this, and like this, and like this, and like this.
Jake:那咱可不知道
Jake: We have no idea.
Jake:啥也不知道
Jake: Absolutely no idea.
Shure: 真不知道
Shure: Really no idea.
其他人:好非常的形象
Others: Well, that was very illustrative.
Lucia:哈哈对吧
Lucia: Haha, right?
其他人:对非常形象
Others: Yeah, very illustrative.
Lucia:对特别详细
Lucia: Yeah, very detailed.
Katrina: 这这哦这就是菜鸟一个
Katrina: This is, oh, this is a newbie.
Lucia:对它里面好像只发个菜鸟
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like they only sent a newbie.
Lucia:和一个别的什么
Lucia: And something else.
Katrina: 今天得把这取回来
Katrina: We need to retrieve this today.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人:味太对了
Others: The flavor is just right.
Jake:走走走要撞墙
Jake: Move, move, move, you're gonna hit the wall.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人:要有要一个人过来给你
Others: Someone needs to come over and...
Jake:哈哈哈嚯
Jake: Hahaha, oh.